it's much easier now to gain them but
it's harder to last you know I want to
be famous like the Kardashians who are
famous for just being famous Fame in its
earliest forms is some sense that human
beings need something beyond themselves
so they almost invented gods as a way of
explaining what happened next and if
there are gods there's going to be
contact with gods some people are going
to be closer to them than others the
word celebrity itself in the 1400s still
meant the celebration of the sacred the
period where the nature of fame changed
from people attributing godlike
qualities to it was when Charles the
first was executed something big had
changed and part of that is the sense of
self making that becomes prominent at
this period the idea that you don't have
to be rich you do not have to be an
aristocrat to be a person of fame we
begin to enter into a situation where
the people become celebrities
he represents the the cult of
personality that we now know today Oscar
really was at an essence celebrity
his his philosophy of life was that the
point of life is self-realization just
as the point of art is self-expression
you have to bring out what it is inside
you the famous people in the 1880s were
politicians scientists doctors writers
by 1920 it was singers sportsmen actors
and the reason for that is the invention
of film which gives you the illusion of
being in touch with somebody and close
to them and forming bonds with them
without ever meeting
Warhol was at the time in the 60s
creating this real buzz around him and
sort of creating this iconic figure that
people flocked to and he and he
certainly influenced the people and the
scene around in New York City and you
could you can think about that today
with people who really influenced the
social scene today whether it might be
somebody like Kim Kardashian and the
followers that she has who want to look
like her physically there's sort of a
draw to wanting to be that figure
wanting to be that famous I think about
Warhol right now and this era that we
live in with everybody taking selfies
and these images of themselves and
thinking back to Warhol when he filmed
himself eating a hamburger I mean he was
one of the pioneers of putting the
camera turning the camera on oneself
think about NZ wall now with an iPhone
that would be the best Instagram account
to follow right why so many people are
attracted to celebrities is that we live
in an age of profound anxiety part of
that is wanting acceptance and approval
in life you want to be accepted by
people and you wanted to be approved by
people who are the people that have paid
most to be accepted and approved
celebrities
[Music]
some people document their life which
means that they don't lie they just have
a camera rolling and some people create
their life so the actually staged a
picture they actually staged an outfit I
think that this will be the difference
between a good influencer and a bad
influencer you have to be real because
people will feel that whatever you're
telling them to do if it's not real and
if it doesn't come from your heart and
whatever you believe in they will they
know I strongly believe that the more
you go into your the pieces of you that
most people would hide the better of an
influencer you are going to be the more
you're sharing things that people are
like what I'm that way too that's when
people get excited that's when they want
to follow you and it could just be that
this smaller kind of famous idea of
finding on Miche or your tribe people
may come more more to value smaller
individual acts of kindness and of love
and become celebrated for them
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon